Hey guys
I'm Nate welcome back to the workshop in the past grant has shown you a pretty cool experiment that he came up with that involved
Microwaving a large glass jar with a little bit of water in it until it was really full of steam
Pouring out the boiling water and lowering the glass jar down into some ice-cold water
Causes the water to violently rush in and fill the entire container
we're going to try and replicate his experiment and then expand on that idea with a couple other experiments of
Making a vacuum in a jar without using a pump to start off
Let's put a little bit of water in our jar and then microwave it for a couple minutes, so it's nice and hot
take our glass bottle and put out that
So it's still filling with water
But because it took me so long to walk over here from the microwave. It's not giving us the explosive result we're hoping for
It's still pulling in quite a bit of water, though
Clearly we need to act faster, so let's move our setup to the kitchen and try again there
Wow
Yeah that did a pretty good job of filling up with water right there that was pretty incredible
I mean look how full this bottle is that?
Is a very full bottle and so all of that water is
Displacing steam that was inside this bottle so we can see how much the steam
Shrinks as it cools down. That's a lot that is crazy
There's another method of creating a low pressure inside a jar like this that you may have seen before and we're gonna try and replicate
again
it involves lighting a fire inside the jar and
Plugging up the top to get our fire inside the jar let's take a strip of paper towel
Light that on fire with the lighter and then drop it down into the jar at that point
I'll cover the top and we'll see what happens
I took one of these gauges that we use on our vacuum chamber to measure the negative pressure inside our container
And I rigged it up, so I should be able to just pop it down on top of this jar
And if there's any negative pressure that forms inside it we should be able to get a good measure of it
I
Started catching
The flame burns out we should begin to see
Our needle starts to rise there goes that is not a lot of rise we got our needle. We are up to about
two and a half
Maybe three inches of mercury. That's a pretty small result but it is lower pressure
See if it's enough to lift our jar it is is enough to lift our jar buy pressure back in
That's kind of cool. You watch the swirling air inside there
Try and get our piece of paper towel out of the jar that's the fun part a
popular demonstration of what happens when you create the lower pressure inside the jar is to see if you can take a hard-boiled egg which
Does not fit through the neck of the jar
Light the fire down inside and have the lower pressure pull the egg through the neck of the jar
Inside the bottle let's try and see if that work
So we've got air expanding inside there from the heat
Now as it burns all the air up
some beautiful that just pulled it right down into the jar that worked great, so now we have a jar full of smoke and
An egg that we can't get out because it doesn't fit out of the neck
There's a whole lot of
remnants of our burned paper towel
inside the jar and I'm filling with water and in addition to clearing out the burn paper towel the water rising up also does a
Great job of displacing all of the oxygen less smoke. That's filling our jar
So it should be easier to do this experiment again after we pour out the water
Or we'll try and pour out the water in the egg. Yolk plug it up. Oh it did
Well, there is an egg
Plugging up our jar. It's a pretty good plug right there in an attempt to get the egg out
I'm gonna see what happens if I pour a little bit of liquid nitrogen into our jar then flip it upside down
Hopefully keeping the nitrogen behind the egg so the nitrogen will expand
Increase the pressure and push the egg out this might not work at all oh
We did that worked great now we have a jar full of nitrogen gas as well our egg a little worse for the wear
Being sucked into a bottle and then blown back out of the bottle so that worked pretty well
And now I want to try combining the two ideas
I want to put a little bit of water in our bottle microwave it up so it's nice and hot again
And then use our pressure gauge on the bottle as we lower it down into our iced water
To see how much of a vacuum we pull just by shrinking the steam instead of replacing it with the ice-cold water
Once our microwave is finished cooking. I'll take it out pour out the water
I'm going to add one large marshmallow down inside it because marshmallows in a vacuum are always fun
And then I'm gonna put our pressure gauge on top of the bottle and lower it down into our ice water
We let it out
Fit a marshmallow in it doesn't have a lot of spare space
There we go now we get our negative pressure gauge
Onto our container and start lowering it down into the ice water to cool down all of the steam
Inside the bottle you can already see how much the gauge is raising
And if you look down into that bottle you can also see our marshmallow. It's starting to grow
Our marshmallow is also very soft because it's in contact with our very hot glass oh
Wow
We're already at 21 inches of mercury a pretty big marshmallow. It's certainly a less convenient way of making a vacuum chamber
Than with our actual vacuum pump, but it is working
All right, I think we've about hit our limit with our vacuum pump at this altitude. We can usually pull about 26
Maybe 26 and a half so this is pretty seriously empty
There is almost nothing except that marshmallow inside this jar here is an unexpected marshmallow and are
Heated by the glass and expanded marshmallow, you can see a pretty good sized difference there now to break the seal
I'm just gonna pull up on the rubber a little bit, and it should be able to pop right off
Smushed
now it's just like a
Wrinkled melted husk of a marshmallow. There is one more thing. I'm going to try that's pretty similar
I'm going to wash out this marshmallow add a little bit of water nuke this thing in the microwave again
And once it's really hot. I'll take it out and then I'm gonna see how many of these eggs
I can get it to suck down into the jar as the pressure drops cooling it down in our water
In an effort to get our jar to pull as many eggs inside of it as we can
I've got a
PVC tube that we should be able to fit our hard-boiled eggs down into in a line when the jar is ready
I should be able to flip the PVC tube up put it over the neck of the jar and then lower it down into the
water
And hopefully as the steam cools off and it forms a vacuum inside the jar it will pull the eggs in one after another
I've never tried this before though so we'll see if it works
There we go we can see the eggs backed up to the pipe, I think we've got 10 eggs in this PVC pipe
Hopefully we can get 10 eggs sucked down into our jar
I
Think let me like the last one
That's it. That's it well. Good news and bad news bad news is we shattered our jar
The thermal shock I guess it was so hot and then being dropped into the ice water
that just broke it right up, but
Before it completely fell apart
We had enough low pressure
To pull 10 eggs through our tube into the jar that was pretty entertaining
That worked great
But that's never been done before
creating vacuum inside of a glass jar with a couple unorthodox methods
We were able to drop a piece of burning paper towel down inside and with our vacuum gauge
We saw that we pulled about 4 inches of mercury which isn't a ton?
But it was enough that we were able to lift the jar with it that low pressure
Also had enough strength to suck a hard-boiled egg down inside of our jar
Which was entertaining to get back out using a little bit of liquid nitrogen poured in behind the egg?
We also used boiling water and steam and then cooled it off in ice water to get the change in volume from the steam being
Fully expanded to contracting down a lot
We were able to get a lot of low pressure using that method we pulled almost 25 inches of mercury
Just by cooling our jar down in some iced water. That's not a full vacuum, but it is very low pressure
I thought it was very entertaining taking our jar full of hot steam lowering it down into some ice water with a tube of eggs
Above it and they all just got sucked down into it. It was really interesting. I love that noise it just
Pulling him down in
We did unfortunately have our jar shatter as a result of the change in temperature from the boiling heat to the ice-cold water
So unfortunately we were not able to pour liquid nitrogen into the whole jar full 10 eggs
Turn upside down and have it just shoot them all back out which is something
I wanted to do and we might have to try that again in the future eggs are cheap steam. Is cheap overall
It's a really cool experiment that shows what kinds of vacuum pressure you can get without owning vacuum pump
Hey guys. Thanks for watching if you're not a subscriber yet
Just hit the bomb to get in the club if you missed our last video or want to see it again
Just click up here at the top click down there if you want to see what the internet thinks that you should watch next
That's it for now. Have fun. Be safe and see you tomorrow